(peaceful music)
- [Woman] The idyllic
islands of French Polynesia
may seem like a relaxing paradise
of pristine reefs and clear waters,
but take a dip below the surface.
Are you ready for a swim?
Fakarava is a rectangular shaped atoll
located in French Polynesia
in the South Pacific Ocean.
The southern parts of Farkarava
is known as the gray shark wall
due to having the highest concentration
of gray reef sharks in the world.
Since 2006, the sharks have
been protected from fishing,
which is attributed to
their population increase.
During the day the
sharks are fairly docile
and conserve energy, ready
to hunt their pray at night.
Although the exact number of sharks
found Fakarava is uncertain,
with only 650 human residents,
it's likely the people are outnumbered.
(digital gong)